bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 27 avril
et merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale et pour commencer ce
journal une information politique samedi
dernier la section jeune udi des ivines
a élu son nouveau président toute
l'après-midi jusqu'à 18h les adhérents
étaient invités à venir voter une seule
liste était proposée à 28 ans c'est Marc
le rouge qui est donc devenu le
président des Jeunes udi yvelinois
commercial de profession il est entré à
l'UDI en 2013 Marc le rouge est
actuellement élu au développement
économique à l'emploi et au transports
aux clés sous-bois ville udi sa priorité
être plus présent sur le terrain et se
faire connaître auprès de la population
écoutez-le il était au micro de Camille
Lambert on va écouter parler les gens on
va euh leur poser des questions on va
les écouter et puis on va on va faire
connaître nos idées centristes et
essayer de s'enrichir aussi de toutes
ces rencontres qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de de
jeunes que soit dans les ivelines ou
ailleurs qui qui se tournent vers le
Front national on a dans les ivelines la
seule ville Front Nationale des
d'île-de-fance donc nous on veut passer
un message un message beaucoup plus
positif un message qui parle de
République d'Europe d'espoir et pas du
tout un message mortifère comme est
aujourd'hui envoyé par le FN un petit
peu partout et les chiffres du chômage
pour le mois de mars ont été communiqués
hier paôul emploi vient d'annoncer un
très fort recul du chômage avec 60000
inscrits de moins en catégorie A celle
qui regroupe les personnes n'ayant pas
du tout travaillé dans le mois un tel
recul mensuel constitue même un record
depuis septembre 2000 une baisse qui ne
s'est pas fait ressentir dans les
Yvelines dans le département on
enregistre + 1,1 % de chômeurs en plus
les ivelines enregistreent la plus forte
hausse annuelle avec 5,8 % soit 5080
chômeurs en plus ils étaient 96060 en
mars 2016 le nombre de demandeurs toute
catégorie confondu a baissé de 0,1 %
pour la région Île-de-France il a en
revanche progresser de 3,1 % sur un an
et prenons la direction de morpa les
musulmans de morpa pourront bientôt
bénéficier d'une mosquée depuis
plusieurs mois l'association des
musulmans de morpa a commencé la
rénovation d'un local de 100 m² dans le
quartier des friche un lieu cultuel mais
aussi culturel qui fera office de
structure pour plusieurs associations
qui apporteront un soutien aux jeunes du
quartier le projet qui nécessite un
investissement de 17000 € devrait être
terminé d'ici la fin du mois de juin les
précisions de William l et Guillaume
leskerer on passe
ici à l'espace dédié aux différentes
activités c'est ici dans ce local de 100
m Carr du quartier des friches de morpac
qu'une mosquée verra le jour d'ici le
mois de juin un chantier de 17000 €
entièrement financé par l'association
des musulmans de Mor qui a déjà levé la
moitié des fonds la première fonction de
ce lieu-là va être un lieu d'activité
culturelle et un lieu d'activité
cultuelle aussi pour une raison très
simple parce que là où vous avez du
culte vous avez un local qui est ouvert
pratiquement toute la semaine donc plus
accessible et donc on peut être plus
réactif en cas de problème quand il faut
éventuellement faire quelque chose
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de nos jeunes une
salle de prière avec un espace pour les
hommes et pour les femmes calligraphie
apprentissage de la langue arabe ou
cours de civisme les activités seront
dispensées par plusieurs associations de
la ville grosso modo ça va bénéficier à
peu près à 80 familles euh donc quand on
dit 80 familles c'est à la fois les
personnes adultes qui pourront venir
faire leur prière ici mais aussi les
jeunes de ces familles-là qui auront
comme je vous l'ai dit un local dédié à
pas mal d'activités qui vont les qui
vont les concerner auparavant les
musulmans de morpa devaient se rendre
dans les mosquées d'é lancours
l'objectif de Mostefa ouvrir le local
pour le début du mois de
Ramadan et demain jeudi 28 avril le
projet de loi de travail de la ministre
myiam elcomery à nouveau confronté à
l'épreuve de la rue le projet de loi je
le rappelle sera examiné par l'Assemblée
nationale à partir du 3 mai donc mardi
prochain demain les syndicats appellent
à la mobilisation partout en France pour
nous en parler ce soir en plateau avec
nous notre invité Axel person bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire général CGT
des chemineau de trappe alors selon vous
demain le mouvement va-t-il encore être
suivi oui le mouvement demain notamment
en terme de participation à la
manifestation va être suivi demain jeudi
28 avril et les grèves seront également
nombreus dans le secteur privé et dans
le secteur public et il faut aussi
préciser que les cheminaux seront
évidemment dans les manifestations et
pour certains d'entre eux en grève
demain mais il était déjà hier contre
les attaques spécifiques dont ils ont
été l'objet à savoir la destruction
annoncée de leur conditions de travail
qui a été annoncée d'ici le 1er juillet
mais ils seront également dans le combat
pour le retrait de la loi de travail
alors le mouvement se fait plus dur la
CGT d'ailleurs appelé à la contestation
tion pour que la constation s'amplifie
c'est ça oui tout à fait la CGT appelle
à organiser des assemblées générales
dans toutes les entreprises et tous les
services publics pour organiser la grève
déjà et voir dans quelle mesure les
salariés sont en capacité de reconduire
la grève pour obtenir satisfaction sur
le rendication que ce soit sur le
retrait de la loi travail pour
l'ensemble du salariat mais aussi pour
toutes les attaques spécifiques qui ont
lieu dans tous les secteurs et les
cheminaux ne sont pas en reste puisque
eux aussi sont soumis à des attaques
très violentes en matière notamment de
destruction annoncée de leur conditions
d'existence alors finement ce mouvement
cré une espèce de solidarité il y a par
exemple le mouvement à des nuits debout
qui s'oppose aussi à cette loi le projet
crée vraiment une cristallisation de la
population contre le gouvernement
comment expliquer finalement que le
gouvernement ne puisse pas faire marche
arrière bah déjà le gouvernement n'a pas
envie de faire marche arrière tout
simplement parce que les intérêts qu'il
sert c'est-à-dire ceux du patronat lui
commande de ne pas céder mais il a noté
malgré tout que certaines dispositions
du projet de loi de travail ont été
retirées sous la pression des
manifestants et des grvistes et c'est
aussi le cas d'ailleurs pour les
cheminau où le gouvernement et la
direction sont contrat à quelques menu
concession c'est évidemment largement
insuffisant mais ça prouve aussi que la
seule façon de faire bouger les lignes
c'est en se mettant massivement en grève
en se mettant massivement en
manifestation donc aujourd'hui la seule
façon de faire reculer le gouvernement
ce sera de poser la question de la grève
et sa reconduction dans l'ensemble des
secteurs et c'est ça qui va être mis à
l'ordre du jour pour le mois de mai et
je tiens à préciser d'ailleurs que
certains conducteurs à l' SNCF de train
par exemple sur la ligne C ont déjà fait
le choix de reconduire la grève
aujourd'hui alors on onendra dans
quelques instants mais des négociations
pourant ont été faites justement après
les précédents mouvements donc avec les
syndicats avec les étudiants est ce qui
notamment la colère du medev qui pense
lui que justement le le la loi est vidée
de son sens vous nêtes pas d'accord pour
vous la loi est encore trop trop dur il
faut complètement l'abroger il n'y a pas
une négociation suffisante euh le projet
de loi nous on maintient notre
revendication de retrait de la loi
travail bien évidemment parce que les
quelques menus concession accordé sous
la pression des grvistes ne modifi pas
évidemment le fond du problème qui est
un recul social généralisé dans toutes
les entreprises et ça ça reste en l'état
et malgré on va dire les la mascarade du
patronat qui fait semblant euh de ne pas
s'en satisfaire en réalité il le sait
très bien que le fond du problème le
fond du texte à savoir la hiérarchie
l'inversion de la ce qu'on appelle la
hiérarchie des normes c'est-à-dire la
possibilité pour des entreprises de
déroger au code du travail aux
conventions collectives dans un sens
plus défavorable et tout à fait maintenu
et évidemment ça ça nous pose évidemment
un problème énorme et on compte le
contester et ce jusqu'au bout des
possibilités pourtant le le le la la lo
le projet de loi va être examiné par le
Sénat vraiment aucune négociation n'est
possible il n'y a pas des points
vraiment qui si ils sont enlevés
finalement euh pourrait vous mettre
d'accord sur cette loi bah c'est le
projet de loi est dans sa totalité un
texte extrêmement rétrograde donc
évidemment comme toujours on a toujours
on est toujours disponible pour discuter
mais uniquement sur la base
d'amélioration de nos conditions de vie
et de travail et pour ça on sera
toujours disponible pour discuter et
pour voir comment on peut faire mais ce
n'est pas du tout ça la philosophie
actuelle du gouvernement du patronat qui
veut lui au contraire passer en force et
imposer ce texte contre la vie
d'ailleurs de la majorité de la
population sans parler évidemment de
l'Ave des org syndicales mais surtout
contre la majorité de la population et
des salariés de ce pays est-ce que fin
finalement aujourd'hui le dialogue
social est encore possible où il y a une
vraie rupture avec le gouvernement il y
a une rupture avec le gouvernement mais
pour ma part je ne pense pas qu'il on
peut vraiment parler de dialogue social
en ce sens que quand on se retrouve
autour des ce qu'on appelle parfois
l'étable de négociation les deux parties
ne sont pas égales puisque l'une à
savoir la patrique patronale et
gouvernementale dispose il faut le
rappeler quand même du pouvoir de
décision dans les entreprises de
sanction et la possibilité aussi de
licencier ce que nous avons pas nous en
tant qu'ouvrier ou en tant qu'employé de
l'autre côté de la table donc ce n'est
pas un un dialogue de égal à égal et
c'est pas nous qui faisons les lois
c'est eux qui les font et c'est eux qui
ont le pouvoir en réalité et nous la
seule façon qu'on a de se défendre c'est
se mettre en grève c'est de cesser le
travail pour défendre nos intérêts alors
justement vous en parlez tout à l'heure
la grève illimitée elle est envisageable
elle est très clairement mise à l'ordre
du jour au chemin de fer sur la question
évidemment de nos revendications
spécifiques qui sont à cell de savoir le
gouvernement a publié un projet de
décret et de convention collective qui
s' venait à s'appliquer en l'état
occasionnerait des reculs immense en
matière de conditions d'existence pour
les cheminaux avec des pertes de jours
de repos des amplitudes maximales
rallongées des amplitudes de repos entre
deux services et courté et une
dégradation de la réglementation du
travail qui est très sévère alors que la
réglementation que nous avons déjà la
SNCF est déjà dérogatoire au code du
travail dans un sens plus défavorable
donc à partir de là que le vu que le
gouvernement et le patronat que ce soit
pour les attaques sur les cheminaux ou
pour l'attaque sur la loi de travail ne
veulent pas reculer bah oui on va poser
la question de la reconduction de la
grève et ce pendant le mois de mai et
certains cheminaux d'ailleurs ont fait
le choix d'y rentrer actuellement et
c'est le cas notamment sur la ligne C
merci beaucoup Axel alors je le rappelle
le rassemblement aura lieu sur Paris
demain à partir de MIDH ou 14h on ne
sait pas encore ce n'est pas encore
défini place d'enfer rocherau Merci à
VOUS loisir à présent découvrir la
région parisienne autrement c'est l'idée
de l'association Le Voyage métropolitain
le collectif organise la découverte de
nouvelles villes et de nouveaux paysages
ce samedi la destination choisie était
Saint-Quentin en iveline camille lombert
a suivi ces randonneurs urbains d'un
nouveau genre
regardez sac à dos carte ique et
appareil photo ce sont des explorateurs
d'un nouveau genre qui se sont retrouvés
samedi à la gare de sa qutin en Yveline
ils sont une centaine à s'être déplacé
parfois de très loin pour venir
découvrir l'agglomération yvelinoise
j'ai trouve l'initiative très bien quoi
de de pouir visiter la banlieu de
manière intelligente et de redécouvrir
en fait ce que ce qu'on ignore je dois
dire qu'en faitamais mis les pieds ici à
Saint-Quentin je sais que de l'ouvrier
avait fait quelque chose d'important
historiquement sur l'aménagement et et
du plan et donc en fait l'idée c'est de
voir ce que c'est devenu quoi ce que je
fais aujourd'hui c'est ma troème rando
avec cette organisation et puis oui
comme je connais pas cette partie de
l'île-de-fance je suis ravie de
participer avec
métropolitain à cette randonnée que je
ne ferai pas seule on peut passer aussi
bien d'un immeuble un champ à une Mar
une rivière c'est extraordinaire
j'adore découverte des arcades de la
Sourderie puis direction la ville de
trappe en passant par la colline des
lancours et l'abaylie des Templiers
depuis depuis 2 ans le collectif le
voyage métropolitain organise ses
randonnées d'un nouveau genre une fois
par mois il offre ainsi aux participants
la possibilité sur un ou deux jours de
se rencontrer d'échanger mais surtout
d'appréhender un territoire différemment
l'objectif c'est de prendre un peu de
recul aussi sur son propre espace de vie
en considérant l'agglomération
parisienne comme un espace de vie
c'est-à-dire c'est une entité urbaine
cohérente ou pas mais qui a beaucoup de
fragmentation spatiale sociale et donc
en fait on connaît très peu cette énorme
ville les futurs voyages métropolitains
se dérouleront à bonuil sur Marne ou
encore près de Melin une manière de
voyager à seulement quelques kilomètres
de chez
soi et avant de fermer ce journal nous
allons parler de sport Lig Montin Sid
Dialo s'est lancé le défi de courir son
premier marathon en octobre 2010 à 55
ans presque 6 ans plus tard le sportif
en totalise plus d'une centaine dont
neuf ultraarathons des compétitions
qu'il pratique pied nu depuis octobre
dernier regardez son portrait il est
signé Camille Lambert et Michel
midoro Sid Dialo 61 ans est un mordu de
course à pied ligne Montain réalisé en 5
ans et demi 133 marathons et 9
ultraarathons dans 51 pays sur 7
continents son addiction au running est
récente le sportif a disputé son premier
42 km le 10 octobre 2010 à Chicago
jusqu'en
2010 j'étais comme les 7 milliards euh
d'humains d'humains qui pensaient que le
marathon c'est c'est pas pour eux c'est
pour des gens exceptionnels j'ai eu la
chance euh d'avoir êté affecté à Chicago
comme consul général adjoint de France
et le marathon de Chicago est
extrêmement populaire donc pendant 2 ans
j'ai applaudi les coureurs et puis la 3è
année j'ai décidé de me faire applaudir
par les autres très vite si didialo est
devenu accro au marathon le sportif en
totalise 48 sur dans l'année 2013 il
réalise son meilleur temps en 2012 au
marathon de Berlin en Allemagne en 3h 14
minutes et 13 secondes une performance
anecdotique pour le coureur donc la
performance non c'est l'expérience qui
m'intéresse quand je cours euh je
discute avec les coureurs qui sont pas
très fatigués qui veulent bien je
discute avec les spectateurs en octobre
dernier lin Montin décidé d'enlever ses
chaussures pour courir pied nus à
l'occasion du marathon de Zagreb en
Croatie depuis cette date alète n'a plus
remis ses baskets en compétition notre
corps est fait pour marcher et courir
pied nu pas avec les chaussures alors
quand les gens me voient pieds nus les
coureurs ils disent il y en a qui disent
bravo oh c'est très bien mais les autres
qui savent pas oh là là oh là là comment
il fait vous navez pas mal au pied ça
fait pas très mal vous n'avez pas froid
au PED vous n'avez pas chaud parce que
les gens ils pensent que je passe pour
quelqu'un de bizarre alors que on devait
tous
courir le marathon et le faire pied nu
prochain marathon pour Sid Dialo le 16
juillet dans la montagne d'Andor une
course qu'il espère courir pied
[Musique]
nu et c'est à présent la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi tout
de suite vous retrouvez kque votre
magazine culturelle sur 50 ans divine
présenté par Sephora Namani quant à moi
je vous retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente
soirée